good morning people apparently the Hells
Angels own that brothel out there out on
80 we're doing a program to hand in your
gun for uh yeah handguns range that's
what the poster said yeah yeah wanted us
to sponsor that you know but up terror
said oh hey you guys can I help you sir
I would just the lady out front said
that maybe I could talk to Trudy for a
second the lady out front was wrong sir
we are in a meeting she is working right
now hi 25 seconds no sir what are you
doing how are you good I got you this
yeah can you turn around god I was just
wondering if you'd like to maybe go grab
a cup of coffee sometime look - all
right so I guess I'll I'll call you or
something okay
what's your number you can just call
Nathan wonder you can just stop by here
any time it would be fine if you wanted
to stop by at any time or a great 3232
inconvenient
it wasn't it inconvenient pullin Craig
pullin Craig pullin okay see you later -
yeah - Oh a charge sittin in a tree
shut up you don't think it's cute you
think it's funny and you think it's
pathetic and you think it's sad Fu Fu
and you
can everyone see this holy through the
computer pu l li m what should we do no
we can't do that we have nothing we have
no evidence oh my god sure if we jump on
him with no evidence Trudy will say it's
just because we're trying to come / life
again find his home address find his
home address we need to get close to him
we need to find out what we can find out
I'm taking Trudy to Sears for a makeover
later and I will have some girl talk
time and I will find out what she knows
about him the Google site the sheriff's
computer don't use Google you've been
looking up too much pornography and you
forgot how the regular sheriff's
computer works
[Music]